Graduating class, hear me well on this day.
On this day, when you have reached the hilltop...
...and you are deciding on next jobs, next steps, careers, further education,...
...you would rather find purpose than a job or career.
Purpose crosses disciplines.
Purpose is an essential element of you.
It is the reason you are on the planet at this particular time in history.
Your very existence is wrapped up in the things you are here to fulfill.
Whatever you choose for a career path, remember the struggles along the way...
...are only meant to shape you for your purpose.
When I dared to challenge the system that would relegate us...
...to victims and stereotypes with no clear historical backgrounds,...
...no hopes or talents, when I questioned that method of portrayal,...
...a different path opened up for me.
I don't know what your future is,...
...but if you are willing to take the harder way,...
...the more complicated one,...
...the one with more failures at first than successes,...
...the one that has ultimately proven to have more meaning,...
...more victory, more glory, then you will not regret it.
Now, this is your time.
The light of new realization shines on you today.
Howard's legacy is not wrapped up in the money that you will make...
...but the challenges that you choose to confront.
As you commit to your past, press on with pride...
...and press on with purpose.
God bless you.
I love you, Howard.
Howard forever.